que se passe-t-il dans la maison des
windsor
le prince harry et magna com annonce
vouloir prendre leurs distances de la
monarchie dans un communiqué de leur
compte instagram
le duc et la duchesse de sussex écrivent
nous avons l'intention de renoncer au
rôle de membre senior de la famille
royale et de travailler pour devenir
financièrement indépendants il ajoute
nous prévoyons partager notre temps
entre le royaume uni et l'amérique du
nord tout en continuant à honorer notre
devoir auprès de la reine et le common
word
une décision qu'ils auraient meurent et
après des mois de réflexion
déjà en octobre dernier lors d'un séjour
en afrique du sud
meghan markle confié aux journalistes de
mtv qu'elle avait du mal avec la
pression médiatique
surtout après avoir eu un enfant peu de
gens m'ont demandé si j'allais bien dit
elle mais c'est un sentiment réel à
l'abri des caméras quand le bahreïn
[Applaudissements]
après son mariage en grande pompe avec
le prince l'ancienne actrice américaine
est devenue très vite la cible de
critiques de certains tabloïds
on lui reproche un comportement
difficile on la qualifie de duchesses
capricieuse
le prince qui est sixième dans l'ordre
de succession au trône prend sa défense
et dépose plusieurs plaintes contre
cette presse il affirme dans un
communiqué qu'il a déjà perdu sa mère et
qu'il ne veut pas que sa femme devienne
victimes de ces mêmes forces et pour
couronner le tout sa relation avec son
frère le prince william se serait
détériorée
cette saga familiale fait le bonheur des
journaux à sensation aujourd'hui le
couple royal prend ses distances de la
monarchie mais buckingham palace n'a pas
dit son dernier mot
les discussions avec le duc et la
duchesse de ce sexe sont à un stade
précoce écrit-il
nous comprenons leur désir de prendre
une autre voie mais ce sont des
questions compliquées qui prennent du
temps à régler mais les spéculations
vont bon train le site américain tiffany
annonce déjà que le couple va passer une
partie de leur temps au canada
ici à 0 des lions 10 radio canada n'ont
rien